just trying to do
it it's like that dude in [__] squid
games the dude the anxious guy yeah yeah
oh [__] hell oh [__] hell was he
almost puking yes okay that wasn't just
like a nervous F [__] puked in his cup
that's how he got the [__] did he really
no it man the amount of spit that dude
put in his cup yeah yeah and he didn't
make it they should have bro they they
should have made this the Titan
submersible out of that cookie cuz that
thing survived that that guy he's
like it was a full inch of spit in there
e dude it's disgusting I know but he did
the dumbest thing when he pulled it out
he did it on his hand he should used the
back of the tint yeah yeah we're talking
about the squid games reality show yes
we fell for it it's good man it's
[__] so good you know you know you
know what sorry go ahead I was going to
say it's it's it's visceral and it has
anime level plot twists yeah oh that's
my favorite part is that they they give
you this big monologue and backstory
from the character and then in the
middle of it it's like a [__] goodbye
yeah like I just really want to pay for
my mom's cancer trick they're out and
you're like oh my
God yeah it's it's filmed very well it's
yeah it's beautiful it's it's so it's
such a dystopian thing and it's so
[__] I feel so bad that I enjoy it
yeah but I do it feels like the show it
doesn't feel that far off from the show
the actual they yeah I like that they
took every step to make it feel as close
to the real show as possible well I mean
they probably kept all the plans for the
set design they were probably just able
to rebuild it yeah I don't I it looks
the same and it feels exactly the same I
actually Wonder now if Netflix when they
invest well no because he sold it to
Netflix yeah so they probably had to
rebuild everything yeah W damn so I was
reading would have been crazy if they
just had half the set lying around like
oh yeah we just got that yeah yeah yeah
nfx is like oh my god let's go yeah yeah
suck my dick Mr
Beast we were watching that show and
alita's like damn they could do this for
years yeah oh yeah dude it's so fun like
what new seasons of that show oh I would
watch every single one it's so [__]
man it's so like I like the the tone of
it is so fresh it's not like other other
reality shows it's not cuz it's complete
opposite yeah it's so awful just people
America's like my
brother has no legs yeah and uh he's
dying from a flesh eating disease and if
I could
just yeah and then yeah oh
no so I I like I've been seeing all the
Tik toks from the people that were on
the show come up and uh one of the
interesting ones was one of the dudes
that made it through the first one he
somebody asked him why was everyone's
hands in their pockets the whole time
it's cuz he said it took F five hours to
shoot that so each time they were still
it was 45 minutes so everyone so that's
why the girl squatting was like I can't
[__] do it and she starts crying and
breaking down because she was squatting
wall sitting for 45 minutes and they had
heat warmers in their pockets cuz it was
like 24° that's why their noes all red
and Sh like that cuz it's freezing yeah
it took longer I I I saw stuff that was
way longer than 5 hours some people were
like it took like 10 hours to shoot that
just this one so I wonder if they did
that on purpose or if it was like they
had to review the footage each time and
actually figure out who moved and who
didn't move or if it was by Design so
that they could filter out the most
amount of people probably a mixture yeah
but I bet you it's like review yeah yeah
I mean that's the only way you could do
that right yeah just by bringing up the
footage and MH
yeah but I mean I appreciate that they
had make it fair yeah I
know damn what else what else from from
behind the scenes that was the only I've
just been [__] sucking out for this
show sucking out yeah just like a fish
what what do you mean like a c straming
yeah no I mean sck out is like a [__]
poker term but like I just like I'm
watching it at home just like goldfish
ey just like oh yeah yeah same I didn't
look at my phone one time I was just
enthralled but yeah so I saw couple
other ones one of the Tik toks was from
the dude the an the anxious guy and so I
turned it off right away cuz I was like
in the middle of the episode and I was
like I don't want any
spoilers oh [__] that poor guy I mean he
couldn't have done
worse he should have played he should
have played off of Brighton's
desire to push
forward I feel like he should have stood
there and he should have uh looked at
Brighton cuz that dude Brighton wanted
to win so bad 432 yeah okay yeah he
should have looked at 432 and
gone I want you to put your hand on that
umbrella right now I'm not touching
anything ah I felt really bad for him
cuz obviously he has some like
debilitating social anxieties clearly
yeah but like that could not have gone
worse for him yeah literally everything
he did everything the worst he got
bullied man he did like right before
going in him just crying and the guy
being like don't cry man man up or
whatever you're like oh [__] and that
for it to be like the biggest bully
[__] in the show that's also there
with him being like [__] stop crying
[__] you're like oh my God the dude
they laid it up for him to turn it on
them cuz the other guy with the dreads
goes man up man up and he puts his hand
on the star he goes oh man up all right
and he goes hey big dog go to the
umbrella yeah he's like no man up yeah
and then he should have just stood on
that he should have stood on business
yeah yeah instead he's like you're going
to SP on my
you're going to help me you're going to
spit on my cookie come on man come on
and then I laughed so hard when they
were like Circle you'll be playing first
I'm like they don't even play together
stupid yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah and he was like uh turns out
you can't help each other it's against
the rules it's like even if you wanted
to even if it was part of the rules he
couldn't do it yeah that's actually yeah
it's so funny like did he not watch
watch the show yeah no one finished in
the show and then they're like come Spin
and they're like you're going to make it
yeah also you yeah yeah it was right you
know what I thought they were going to
do is I thought I'm puking my cookie
you're going to puke in my cookie right
my C you're going to help me you're
going to puke in my
cookie I did to say when 432 like turned
his head cuz the dude was like crying
and vomiting and he was like trying not
to laugh I laugh so hard I felt that
[__] in my core just that
[__]
just that guy's an [__] man he's
young man that's why he's a dick yeah
he's a [__] man yeah yeah 432 is a
funny guy man yeah but it's it's a
phenomenal show unfortunately it's
really really good here's the thing dude
you need guys like 432 in there to make
it interesting if they didn't have that
guy I agree and I'm looking forward to
seeing him get eliminated there they you
need pivotal villains bro you do squid
game The Challenge the challenge Us
application how far will you go is this
for the next one yeah no
way
um Cody and do Cody and Noel do yeah
squid Games The Challenge I think to win
this you have to be so innocuous and
like socially awkward yeah yeah but you
can't be off-putting no you just have to
stay silent just completely blend in but
you can't it you can't blend in with a
group
either yeah it's like [__] it's like
prison you have to just kind of like be
head down yeah and I've heard this from
other people that have gone to like jail
they say that you don't get [__] with
if you just appear to be doing your own
thing yeah like like all right this dude
is he's probably in here for some [__]
that's why I'm saying you can't really
be with a group no yeah you yeah you
just got to be like in there yeah just
doing whatever which would get boring it
would that that I think would be the
true test if you're just like
psychologically all the time figuring
out like [__] yeah how do I get away
from people yeah yeah and then it's it's
crazy cuz you don't even want to be too
physically dominant either yeah cuz
everyone's like get that guy out yeah
yeah that's the [__] from Survivor it's
a you have to be dead in the middle you
have to blend in and be average by every
by every means you know he's got to be
like a sloth just in your bed all day
yeah ah I think that guy's like a nemic
he we got to worry about
him